from mr you passing uh i played him many
times
and it has never been easy
okay let's go onei for them denying yeah
exactly i think he
he has already played this against me
okay whatever let's just try to
develop the pieces in a reasonable way
and then we will think
goes h6 trying to get b5
okay
yeah that's confusing i'm not saying
okay let's go in and
we need to
so now d5 could be it could be an idea
in some of the lines
yeah b5 is logical once you go a6 you're
normally going to be 5
so here goes b should be seven can we go
on like knight e5 for knight g5
i mean we probably can
feels more logical to go to e5 also
and g5 was also interesting
so actually now in some lines we can
even take on b5
or sudden a b quintx b5 check
so after 95 here yeah maybe now
actually
so let's say we take on b5
um
some queen queen d7 bishop xd5 it seems
to work actually
probably we also have uh
some yeah some normal good moves like
queen f3
for instance winners three let's say
queen f6
yeah takes on d5 we just win the pawn
also looks good
after f6 we go queen h5 check
yeah i don't know let's just go queen f3
so knight xb5 was interesting
i mean i don't see what's uh what's
wrong with it actually but queen of
three
just just seems to be much more simple
we
and we don't show off when when we don't
need to install
we just take a pawn and yeah try to
convert it slowly
when i say take a pawn i mean the lion
queen f6 knight takes d5
queen takes f3 for instance knight xc7
check and then we take on f3
or queen f6 knight takes d5 he takes on
d5 we just go bishop takes d5
and yeah it's a healthy bone it seems
i actually think i saw the the game of
magnus against the same guy
and the star to realize i think in this
game
so magnus was lucky to to get this
knight xf7
so i start to think he could actually
play exactly the same
sequence of moves
don't know why would we care
but um yeah it's interesting i think
yeah magnus in
in one of his banter blisses played
exactly the same guy
it was a scandinavian for sure
and i think yeah
black ended um yeah i ended up wondering
that this knight xf7 idea
okay so this is exactly the pawn we
wanted now we go
a4 to problem before
i guess
right now yeah how should we play this
actually
i mean there are different ways to
to place this so we could just go c4
we could just cancel for now
okay castling shouldn't be dramatically
but i would say
although sometimes sometimes you you
want the king to be in the center
so here goes f6
uh maybe we just go like c4 or maybe
checking c4
okay whatever we can go c4 and then we
can
then we can include the check if we want
also probably it would be a little bit
uh
a little bit more smart to start with
check
okay now there is no more difference i
believe
so we just go c4 he goes c5
we go g5
now he was c5 but then i think it's uh
it's quite bad for black as well
yeah now we go b1 and we control
b so he cannot really fight for the b
file okay
so now i think we can do literally
anything
let's start by playing playing h4
to prevent g5
okay i don't know what uh
what is he doing exactly uh so that's
what he
that's what he wants okay char
then we bring the knight to d6 i guess
okay so now c4 take 6
knight e4 would be better move probably
but it should be still
good enough here
[Music]
removing knight d6 looks safe
yeah but we don't even need to okay
okay now we go 96
starting mate actually
okay and then we go check check
um yeah anything means okay let's take
it on first
yeah so he doesn't have moves we can
just go e5
and improve slowly
goes f5 okay
so after king of three he probably wants
king of five
and 95 which is still uh lost for him
but
we can even avoid that so we just uh
go wire why is the square that he
he cannot some attack
g5
yeah i would say k6 for now
yeah okay